listen this this was worn on purpose
because of this gentleman yeah Bob and I
are uh in that moment we're not getting
along but we get along now
what happened at that moment
okay right uh it's what we call it it's
a pretty good movie yeah Gilmore it you
know made me laugh at least three times
I got three years that's all he needed
I'm really underselling this Abigail
Moore's a classic hey Carol I mean that
is it is you know um I definitely have
to ask you though uh I mean Bob Barker
do you remember like what was the
motivation to put him in the movie or
just because it's so different we we uh
and Bob knows us we initially wrote it
for Ed McMahon Ed McMahon said he was
busy and we we were we were like imagine
if Bob Barker did it he'll never do it
and then we sent it to him next thing
you know Bob Parker whose neighbor was
Chuck Norris at the time stop it and and
Chuck and Bob used to spar and Bob was
like yeah if I get to fight if I get to
throw punches I'm doing it
that's how it happened yeah and then the
rest is history yeah well that was a
good good time for all of us